um i hate the main girl so much i could
not stand her
i i didn't mind her at first but then
when she started to get a bit wingy
later on can i can i okay to get my to
get my opinions
out of the way um what do you guys think
of the
series overall i'm glad that we finally
have some good propaganda for youtubers
i'm glad that we need more youtube
propaganda today youtubers are good
more op youtubers dude i'm so glad i was
like wow
he's a youtuber and he's not an [ __ ]
this is something no no no because
this is amazing because okay so there's
a character
in uh in in japan sinks that is just a
youtuber
and he's a youtuber who's a [ __ ]
superhuman because he can do everything
he's mad shout out
[Music]
the way that he enters in that [ __ ]
fan propelled like
yeah i know and he's just like yeah this
is mine i bought it with my youtube ad
ram
and it's like what videos are you
uploading you're really telling me
you're going to film a video of okinawa
singing and that shit's going to be
monetized
come on millions of people die monetized
no way can we just appreciate that the
character is basically
felix pewdiepie he just he's like
whitehead
like like the time when felix had the
really really i
remember when i met felix and when he
came in on his um
it's like the idealized vision of
pewdiepie like this is this is his final
form right
it just rocks in on a tank we see
pewdiepie
i wouldn't be surprised if he changes
his profile picture to that character
next because it was rio from yeah
it's real it looks like rio yeah but i
guess
when i saw that and as you said it was
probably one of the first times that a
youtuber has been kind of viewed in
a lot more of a positive life positive
fashion it really it goes to show me
that i think masakus is a fan of youtube
yeah
it just it just disappointed me that in
his final scene he didn't
he didn't send them off by going and
don't forget to like and subscribe yeah
very unrealistic there was never
a pull to some there was not one
sponsorship right now
the whole thing come on no rage shadow
i want to imagine he comes in the truck
he came flying away like freezing after
death in the stratosphere and he's like
spots
[Laughter]
very unrealistic yeah okay i'm gonna
what what out of ten was it or was it
good or bad what are you to do okay
i i'm not going to say that it was a 10
i'm i'm gonna give it like a solid seven
i thought it was like a four or five
really you didn't like it nah
i didn't like it either okay here's his
i couldn't stop watching it
yeah but i i didn't i just so many
things i hated
right okay here's the thing this the way
this is like a proper mixed bag for me
yeah same the way i would describe it is
that it's a
four out of ten series with uh some 10
out of 10 scenes
okay it was really weird because some
scenes were [ __ ] amazing
it was like yeah peak you asked first
two episodes absolute bangers no exactly
right and like some of the scenes in
like last two episodes absolutely
bangers as well
like like the scene in the scenes with
the youtuber and like some some of the
death scenes
oh the scene where the guy's running
yeah yeah yeah i think i don't i don't
know what you asker has about that was
amazing
emotional running scenes yeah but it's
and the father's death
completely caught me off guard yeah and
i was like oh cool the one character i
liked
yeah is dead i literally thought like
wow this like after i finished episode
two i thought like this could be a 10
out of 10 if they keep up with like how
good this
is and then we went into the culture and
then they got to the cult
and i was like oh no this is awful this
is actually awful like
the the cold arc for me was so
bittersweet because as a massive fan of
us's stuff i'm like oh this is
so yeah there's a scene what the [ __ ]
was the co-op
what the [ __ ] was it okay i gotta make
the 360 no scope
it was amazing that was amazing that
wasn't the part where i laughed at most
you're the part i laughed most was the
kid
i was just watching it dead serious and
the kid just gets [ __ ] destroyed by
this rock
he was just like it was so perfect
comedic timing
it was just he turns around it's like oh
casa
yeah it was like it was like slapstick
no it was what was that it was no
because i remember i was like properly
i was properly invested in my first two
episodes i probably probably invested
and then like some things just fell
off like as as them as a series went on
right because
like i remember their father dying and
it was he
he died in a really horrific [ __ ] way
yeah and then
nobody really just acknowledged that
they had like just cuts doesn't it yeah
they had like one conversation it's like
oh
you you're forgetting dad and then they
just like
next scene like happy-go-lucky [ __ ]
shopping in a supermarket i'm just like
like if that was real i wouldn't be able
to say anything for like the next five
days
yeah yeah yeah i don't even think about
it and yet for some reason every other
character that dies
after that they have like a full-on
emotional scene that yeah it all
acts out like crazy right yeah yeah it
it something just fell
off about the characters i don't know
what it was about how they were written
but
it just didn't like sometimes they acted
the way i would imagine
people would act and sometimes they just
acted in a completely random way
and then the cult arc happened and i was
like awful okay
okay now now now we've gone from
something fills off to this is just
stupid
so much needed explaining about that
like whole thing where were they getting
all of this food from
where were they getting all of the weed
there's so
much weed like it's just fields of weed
and like in japan like you're just gonna
grow feel completely
they never explain the fact that like
the the the grounds where the cult stood
wasn't affected by the tilting there was
just so much there was so much stuff
when it got to the cold arc where i was
like this is too much
too many holes for me to just like be
like this is okay because at the end of
it all i think the only reason
i was trying to figure out okay what was
the point of this cold arc like like
what were they trying to build
to and i think the only thing that came
out of this cult arc was
just the fact that they got that morse
code talking professor out of there
but why was he there none of this was
explained it was just a slapstick comedy
like like i remember watching the coal
talk and you know that point when you're
like really invested in the show and
then yeah
you go from being invested to just
laughing at how bad it's become
yeah that was the cold talk for me and i
couldn't get invested back into the show
after that yeah it hurt too much after
the cult arc happened and the fact that
they just were like
okay if the old man is addicted to
morphine i'm fine with that
but they didn't even build up to that at
all they could have showed some kind of
you know right right like they could
have maybe shown him taking some pills
the fact that the old man shot that kid
at the end of episode
four three yeah yeah and then they were
like and then he and then he was like oh
i'm sorry you know whatever
i didn't mean to shoot you let me fix
your game boy dude you just [ __ ]
shot my kid with the intent to kill it
like if he
didn't have his [ __ ] ds like he he
would be dead
so you're just going to let him behave
actually the last ps vita
to be fair though at the end of episode
4 when the kid got shot i was like oh
thank god he's dead
my god that kid was [ __ ] annoying
okay did you you
did you want yourself to dubbed i
watched both i watched sorry i
like i i literally i was like i watched
the dub something felt off i watched the
sub and for the first time my [ __ ]
life i i could not stand like the voice
i think in this it was really like i get
it that they're supposed to be
like native in both but then i feel like
they should have got people who are
native and both it's terrible
because when they whenever he said let's
go it's just like that's nice yeah it
sounds
really old
well they could have even have just
gotten someone with a similar voice type
who speaks english you know what i mean
what is it what is it about
you also did this in devil may cry baby
as well where ryo's
english was just stop doing this stop
doing this
and yet somehow they can't get i made
this joke on twitter but
i think it was the second to last
episode where they were in russia yeah
and they got those like three nurses who
could speak
perfect russian and yet they can't get a
single english
voice actually yeah it was like why how
was it so hard yeah because in the dub
how do they deal with the
the do uh bilingualness they they didn't
really they just the boy just always
spoke english
so that's that's why they mention it at
all that you could speak
i mean like they kind of do i wanted
them to just be like i want to meet my
old car son
[Laughter]
it's just like a reverse is it like a
huge plot point because then later on
when the like the barrage comes with the
japanese only
oh the japanese kkk
the whole you know the the dynamics of
that boat just the engineering standards
of it were all horrific
you couldn't handle waves like waves
could just come off they literally burst
into the lane
no reason oh my god sorry i just got
yeah it was the i got
the engineering the more the more we're
discussing this the more i'm regretting
giving it a seven
no no like the emotions it gave me were
ten yeah yeah yeah yeah but like like
let's let's let's not forget that they
also added
a woman who could speak to the dead that
was just what's up with you never
explained
why why did they show us like there were
several points in the coal talk
show her sex scene i don't need to see
that
there was two points i burst out
laughing one one was the kid dying and
the second one was like the [ __ ]
mexican standoff
where she just brings a [ __ ] samurai
somewhere i was like is this kill bill
is this a kill bill that was such a
quentin tarantino scene where it's like
this there's a guy with a bag full of
gold bars with a gun and she just rocks
up with a samurai sword and the guy just
walks up the stairs is like
uh and i'm just like what am i watching
i thought i was watching like a disaster
movie
and it's turned into [ __ ] kill bill
it was just i couldn't stop taking sick
i couldn't stop laughing at that point
what did you guys think of the the last
episode
it was a really [ __ ] hated the last
step yeah the last episode just kind of
dragged out for a little bit too
the last episode was uh remember when
the olympics was meant to happen
right now well this is this is awkward
don't forget the paralympics too just
gotta make sure
i mean i'm sure it would have hit harder
because the olympics would be happening
right now
yeah if this was released right now i'd
be like oh that's that's a
pro gamer move there you are so i i see
i see you but but now that the olympics
isn't happening it was just one giant ad
for the olympics
i didn't want to say that but like it
definitely like felt a little
a little ad-like like yeah look how
amazing the olympics are and it's like
it's like yeah we know yeah we know how
good the olympics are or
how good it should have been because i i
didn't like maybe i
was i wasn't paying attention to this
but i saw a lot of people commenting
saying that the show was like very
political
at times and i was thinking like i don't
know if it was that political
people are trying to put that on it like
i didn't get that did you get that vibe
no not really yeah
i mean maybe they were talking about the
rap scene uh maybe
which i liked i like the rapture i liked
the rap scene well that was uh this this
doesn't this is a really random scene
but i'm all for it it was a good scene
it was random though i was like i don't
know what this is but we can keep doing
it but it's such a
awesome move where you know he was just
like okay i really want to tell
people how much i love japan but how
much japan
sucks but not make us super political
yeah freestyle rap baby let's do it
yeah so originally was the rap in
japanese in the japanese stuff
yeah yeah cause like i didn't notice
because i at that point i was just
purely watching the english dub
and it was all in english and it it was
really really done well so i didn't know
if it was a case where they just like
had that one specific scene in english
um but no like i really enjoyed that i
really enjoyed the last two episodes
not the last two episodes like episode
nine and the one before that yeah those
are two really strong episodes yeah
they had like like i said i wasn't
invested in the characters at that point
which is really weird because there were
some scenes that like i felt something
even though i had zero investment in the
story and the characters but
just because of like the sheer
brilliance of some some of the ways
these scenes were directed i was like
yeah man i'm i'm i'm feeling something
even though i really shouldn't be right
now
um did the mom have to die like i was
thinking like i was like did she have to
enter life here for this
because they kind of went like i don't
know if they probably went further but
it was like one minute on the boat oop
it's out of fuel i think it was implied
though that because her
like device hadn't run out of battery
life she was literally going to die but
didn't she have like a solar panel
no no because like that thing hadn't
become busted oh it had
oh [ __ ] so the implication was that she
was going to die oh [ __ ] i didn't pick
that up because
i thought is she just killing yourself
for like the lols here she's just
drowning for like i mean i
think it's like i have to fill in my one
death per episode quarter yeah
at this point it was just they were just
killing characters that's what it felt
like
it felt like they were like every
character was going to die now and we
were just trying to sit through it like
i didn't feel like it was
needed yeah and the one character that
should have died a million years ago
which is the crippled doctor
survived how somehow i don't know how
no like yeah that's that was my biggest
problem with it because it wasn't the
fact that people were dying it was the
fact that
you just knew that was gonna die like it
was it was just okay
here's the scene where this person's
gonna die you know there's no
tension or anything you're just okay
well they're gonna die
and they're dead and everyone's moving
on now and it's sad and you should be
sad
and japan's sinking yeah so like but
youtube are good
so it's really weird though because i
was having this conversation with joey
earlier though i think we could
we can end the spoiler discussion now no
more spoilers well unless unless there's
anything else you guys want to discuss
about the series specifically why all
pro games did he become a league of
legends pro
totally unrealistic and he's not a
little [ __ ]
i mean actually kind of was there
actually maybe not he was yeah maybe he
was a league player
of course dad dies why are you winning
why are you sorry okay